andrew cuomo um embroiled in his uh
scandal now when i say embroiled in the
scandal there remember
again as we've been talking about there
are two scandals here
uh one scandal that that where he is
responsible for the deaths of
thousands of of people in nursing homes
and another scandal where he made
inappropriate comments to women at the
work
in the workplace and
all of the if when you're looking at the
media all the headlines all the
condemnation
from the media from politicians fellow
democrats i mean they're all lining up
to condemn cuomo
but every time you hear any of those
people media politicians
referring to andrew cuomo's scandal they
will always be referring to
the inappropriate comments not the fact
that he killed all those people
and when he was finally forced to give a
press conference and address and give
the tearful apology
it was again for the inappropriate
comments and not the fact that all those
people are dead because of decisions
that he made
so here is andrew cuomo on the much much
less serious scandal here's what he has
to say
i fully support a woman's
right to come forward and i
think it should be encouraged in every
way
i now understand that
i acted in a way that made
people feel uncomfortable
it was unintentional and i
truly and deeply apologized for it
i feel awful about it
and frankly i am embarrassed
by it and that's not easy to say
but that's the truth but this is what i
want you
to know and i want you to know this from
me directly
i never touched anyone
inappropriately i never
touched anyone inappropriately
well he's embarrassed uh it's hard for
him to talk about
very difficult for him poor andrew cuomo
but he supports a woman's
right to come forward
there's that shift to the goal post from
believe all women so i support a woman's
right to come forward of course you do
everybody
is does anyone not support a woman's
right to come forward
is there has is that a point of view
that anyone has expressed at all
does that exist is there an anti-coming
forward position anywhere that's
is anyone saying no you know what i
don't think women have the right at all
i don't think they have the right to
come forward with they feel that
something inappropriate happened they
don't have the right
that's my is anyone saying that no
yes of course you support that right
of course these guys in this situation
they always have to pretend
um that they're grateful
that that women have come forward
against them i'm i'm grateful that
they've come out and
said all these things if what if you are
saying
that their claims are either untrue
or that they have wildly misinterpreted
your actions
um then why would you be grateful
they're saying it
i think it should be encouraged i think
women should be encouraged to come out
and defame me
i think i should do it more often i
couldn't be happier i could not be
happier to be slandered and defamed in
this way
i i think it's just wonderful i
encourage more women to do it in fact
so he's trying to strike a balancing act
there that's impossible to strike but um
again it goes back to this really
doesn't matter compared to um
the real scandal that this is like
and i i i you know when i've when i've
talked about this
i've heard from a lot of people that
have said well they're both bad
you know sexual harassment killing lots
of elderly people
with with the the nursing on policy both
bad
we should condemn them both
you know but that is there is such a
wide gap between these two offenses
that it is like saying um
yeah you know ted bundy was uh was uh uh
or you know john wayne gacy was a was a
serial killer
but he also stole a guy's parking lot at
walmart
and and both of those things are bad
both of those are bad
and they should both we should condemn
them both we need to have a conversation
about both of those things
because they're both bad yeah they are
both bad
but there's really not to put them in
the same sentence to put them in the
same category to lump them all together
under the same
umbrella um is absurd and insane
so the fact that this is what's going to
take him down or you know at least even
if it doesn't take him down that this is
the thing we're talking about is
ridiculous but it's uh we know for the
democrats
it's a pretty clever um strategy it's an
obvious strategy
where they've got this very serious
scandal
involving thousands of of people lost
their lives
um and it's due to a policy that was not
just in new york this implicates other
democrat governors too and so from the
democrat party perspective
we cannot talk about that these are
policies
they supported that were adopted by
several
democrat governors prominent ones too
um can't talk about that so let's give
the public another scandal instead
let's give them a scandal that doesn't
matter that cuomo can easily survive and
even if he doesn't at least he's not
going to take every
everyone down with him uh and so we'll
go with the sexual harassment thing
again
instead yeah i that that is
clearly the strategy it's a brilliant
strategy
in an evil way but it's it's quite
brilliant
and it's working even many conservatives
from what i've noticed have
changed they have uh gone along with
this change of subject
and now when they when when they're
condemning andrew cuomo it's about the
sexual harassment stuff and not the the
dead people
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated